everybody's got these stupid barriers
they put in their own head you got to
resist those goddamn things because they
don't do you any good
and they certainly define the potential
for your future in a negative way
that's not self-serving and it's not
even real this idea that there's no way
to get past the starting block today is
just ludicrous it's crazy and it's just
this this poor thinking and people that
are trapped in bad situations one of the
problems is you feel like this is your
future you feel like you're [ __ ] and
you can't get out of that there's no
hope there's no light at the end of the
tunnel there's no rainbow and if you
feel like that that alone can be
incredibly defining and limiting but if
you look at yourself objectively and say
okay I kind of am [ __ ] here I'm in
credit card debt I'm working in a shitty
job I don't like what I'm doing but I
have some ideas I need to feed those
[ __ ] ideas I need to feed them and
water them and I need to set aside a
certain amount of time every day to just
try to make those things happen you can
do that
I think here's an important thing too I
think failure teaches you things you
don't learn from success I think failure
gives you an opportunity for
self-examination it also gives you a
feeling that is very uncomfortable and
that very uncomfortable feeling helps
you grow and don't look at these
failures as like proof that you suck
look at them as opportunities for growth
look at them as opportunities to be
motivated to do better if you look at
someone who's doing really well like say
if you focus on like Kevin Hart or
someone like that some very famous and
successful comedian all you see is him
now flying around private jets wearing a
new pair of sneakers every day driving
around in Bentley's you just see that
you don't see him being a young kid in
Philadelphia going to open mic nights
there's a there's a progression that
you're not witness to you don't see it
and that takes place in everything it
takes place in author as it takes place
in comedians and musicians there is a
starting point and then with time and
focus and as long as you re-evaluate and
reassess and constantly objectively look
at what you're doing and then pursue it
with passion and focus you get better at
things there's always going to be people
that are luckier than you some of it is
luck and some of it is courage some of
it is putting your ass out there some of
it is trying thing one of the things
that I always like to tell people that I
think you should do is do [ __ ] that's
difficult it's very important to
struggle we have been fed this line of
war [ __ ] that you're supposed to seek
comfort and I don't think you are I
think you're supposed to seek lessons
and you're supposed to seek difficult
tasks and accomplishments and through
those things and through doing things
that are hard to do even if it's just a
[ __ ] 90 minute hot yoga class this
life doesn't have enough of that there's
not enough struggle you don't get to
know yourself without struggle you don't
get to know your boundaries unless you
push them you don't get to know who you
are really
unless you're tested
you